tonight a medium coffee sure actually
what has the most caffeine we've got a
grande macchiato
I think it's did I turn the stove on
[Music]
we're just gonna wait for a few more
people my supposed to be in this meeting
oh wait I didn't even make breakfast
that's why I'm at the coffee shop and
huh what was she talking about I don't
like this job all the day's just blend
together can't even pick out key words
I don't be surprised I got fired home no
I have to poop they definitely think I'm
an adult I should probably stop think to
myself man he could hear her they'll
poop at work my best friend isn't even
really my best friend she has like three
other best friends right with the
bathroom in school I'll hold it or is
that how people get sepsis I need to see
a doctor I need to see a therapist
if you need a drink how am I getting
older and not getting smarter doctors
gonna tell me I'm dying oh god what is
my mom doing she hasn't called in a few
days shut up oh my god I'm glad know
what you hear my thoughts no I hear my
thoughts right who's that what's that oh
no people can hear my thoughts I knew it
you thinking what I'm thinking maybe I
should probably keep going there right
thank you
sorry healthy guys not a drink I just
gotta I gotta quit so oh okay
sir
I left my stove on
[Music]